[Music]
hello welcome to the honest trailer
commentaries those are the iconic drums
of the movie predator and also the
predator I'm supposed to say Gilbert
Betts Joestar that's Dan Merle hello
talk about the Australian to the
predator which you've hopefully just
watched then come back to get our full
uncensored thoughts about this film and
if you stick around to the end you'll
catch some deleted scenes guys this
movie was a hot bag of poop
I wish go ahead no everyone at once I
wish the weeks had been switched so that
one was sitting here for this one
because he actually likes this he
forgave its sins history back and say
when it came out he was feeling I had
long discussions but boy did I not like
this movie yikes and I was so ready to
love it I really wish I had seen this
before we taped all our end of the year
what was this was it yeah this was awful
and I'm choosing to feel bad for Shane
black because I can't imagine this is
what he envisioned but because you know
he's been great as recently as the nice
guys yeah it's weirdly bad for it it's
weirdly bad I think I Ross and I talked
about it because I think we both
reviewed it when it came out I think I
don't remember I forget about these
movies a week after I've seen it's been
10 years this week it was genetically
engineered to be forgot it really seemed
like it but I think our our working
theory was that the studio interfered so
much that at some point shame but I'm
gonna use one of my F words spoiler drop
it at one point Shane black just said
[ __ ] it I'm taking all your notes and
they're all going in the movie so he
just took every studio note that they
gave them every tweak every plot of
everything that Fox came back to it was
and he said yep
in the movies what you wanted that's
what you'll get and that's what you got
was like studio notes in the movie you
wanna have a dog sure he's got a dog oh
the dog can't be evil yeah all right
yeah shoot at me head oh we can't have
him a head okay the dog is good after he
shoots it was like the Kevin Smith story
of working on Superman and someone
wanted executives like giant spider
spider like there was someone who was
just like autism's the next step of
human evolution go yeah and they're okay
why does that have to do with predator
cow okay one and I remain predator suit
great got it yeah done well that was
their fourth choice of ending that's
right it was done showing up then they
rewrote well there's an even lamer one
where it was just like he's like burying
the members of the loonies and he looks
up he's like [ __ ] you man credits like
we need a little something more and then
the third one was it's gonna be either
Ripley or Newt was a pitch with their
face covered because of course neither
would agree Oh God agree to that cuz it
makes zero sense yeah but it'd be like a
weyland-yutani space capsule and then I
probably it's Woody Harrelson with the
goofy blondes like there's gonna be new
text time there's gonna be aliens and
what we got which was the predator but
but like matte black like somewhat like
a tricked-out Honda Civic version of the
predator of like loud loud muffler
exhaust on the predator suit that the
predator sent for us to defeat the
Batman yeah and that's what it looks it
looks like a 90s spike covered like Rob
Liefeld in suit no it looks ridiculous
yeah no it really looks like somebody
put 40 grand into a 10 grand car just
like it's like a predator with a really
big spoiler on it and like some decals
and stuff like that nobody looks really
crappy
ground lighting yeah it's a it's an
ending it's a franchise starter gosh I
don't know man every step of this it's
just bad
yeah and you can see the the struggle to
inject personality and flair into it
because he's there's a lot of banter
whoo boys are a lot of man yeah and that
was because I believe Fred Decker from
the 80s came back and the crackling
dialogue monster squad came back to
co-write this one and it felt like a
movie that was written in the eighties
yeah it definitely felt like Wolfman
didn't have nerds in this movie yeah
just the idea of like hey you know it's
Rex you know that thing that we assume
you know that's what that is yeah he's
got that it was like 30 years ago I
think that's what you can call that
little freak the R word but you know
times have changed so you can't say that
but then say it again there's a new
thing my kids are using about yeah your
mother this your mother back yeah it
felt a bit those the other things the
script felt it like it was written in
the 80s but not in that charming way but
in the thing I'm just like yeah all of
the wrong ways for it to it felt like it
was written in the eighties like it's
not even just like hockey in the
eighties yeah not even from just like an
offensive standpoint we're just sort of
like that was that was used that was
overplayed thirty years ago yeah that
was that was like someone tried to
pretend to be Andrew Dice Clay in the
80s even the dice man it's like the
Seinfeld thing when when he was thought
that the the dentist converted to use to
tell Jewish jokes did that offend you as
a as a Jew he says no that offends me as
a comedian as a movie goer and someone
who likes good writing yeah yeah I did
like
sterling K Brown in this movie I think
he's the only one who is very aware of
the film he was in he's like I'm gonna
chew the scenery and they're not yep
this pack an entire pack a record gun
Percy yeah yeah he had the right kind of
over-the-top attitude for like a
predator sequel but everyone else was
just a charisma void and like you're
getting the worst version of Keegan
yes that's not forgivable I thought it
was a great guy Jacob Tremblay even
Logan Rosen else Logan guy Thomas James
in Logan he's got like really good
charisma like he's you yeah like
watching him
that's over again with Hugh he's fun
Elfi for a game girl yeah oh yeah who is
zero to do this is we should pause wait
what happened this is a very you are
going to be watching this is the final
edit oh because we have Monday off yes
so this will be wrapped the trailer will
be wrapped by the end of the day but
they don't have graphics yet you're
seeing with a rare in progress version
of what these trailers look like
prepared not fascinating without the
magic of Robert Holtby yes wonderful
graphical creations I will say our
editors do fantastic mock-ups yes but
yes so this is the rare unfinished
honest trailer that you're seeing
[Music]
now that the Terminator franchise has
been run into the ground and the Alien
franchise is on life support
under the fingering predator franchise
so he does up on its prey
dust it off and have its base taunt in
the predator did you love the polka I'm
sorry even in the trailer more than one
predator yeah they already used
predators though right yeah predators
was used for the one that Rodriguez
produced right on that was set on the
predator homeworld I know they're there
yes so I don't know man the Predators
the Predators yeah two Raiders three
maybe because it this counts it does
acknowledge it it even has like nods to
like a VP and stuff predator Requiem
[Music]
okay yeah just saying predator
Parabellum no it's just a just a genuine
lack of care for the or confusion about
the movie that you're watching yeah yeah
okay it's the twist you think there's
the predator predator the Predators like
the producers yes all right play a dumb
thing did you love the razor focused
intensity of the first and only good one
this is a film about a team of outcasts
being hunted by an alien and a predator
rebelling against his own people as a
flourish and an autistic boys unlikely
gifts and different one soldier's quest
to clear his name he play a biologist
unraveling the mystery of territory man
evolution
take them all at the same time did this
sloppy mess barely held together by
dialogue written by Shane black
character and predator one he called me
do you know what he calls me huh loonies
outcast soldiers stripped of their ranks
and all the desire to drain movies
there's Thomas King playing
man with moving to rats again that's not
how turrets usually manifests itself and
people knew that in like 1994 I mean
yeah and then there was another ten
years after people knew that in 1994
where movies still did it yeah because
there's like a ten year gap but we now
are now in year 15 of knowing that
that's still not how Tourette's works
but still now we're back in whatever
1080i I do maintain that there is a good
movie to be made of a bus full of let's
say war criminals because all these guys
are like charming were crippled yeah
yeah I shot all these people in the back
I did some things that yeah it's
annoying that they constantly lost sight
of that because that was interesting
yeah like these are people who actually
you know look they don't deserve to die
but you wouldn't feel bad if a predator
killed them right right but the idea
that like they're gonna Walter White
Breaking Bad make you like these
horrible nightmare people because
they're being stalked by a worse thing
like that that's compelling yeah yeah
sure it's predator on the road they got
to get to get to plot point be and
they're being stalked but they have
skills but no one trusts them and like
you know unlikely alliances happen
between them and their guards and stuff
like that's a good predator movie if I
ever write a movie where there's a bus
full of prisoners and they have to get
to where they're going I'm going to name
the prison plot yeah now yeah question I
know the answer is because this movie is
bad chirp uh-huh but Tourette's guy
Thomas Jane yes and Keegan they're arc
is he's very antagonistic towards
Tourette's guy then it's revealed right
before they die that they love each
other I think they just have our mutual
respect that comes from both being half
killed by a predator and I guess we had
more in common than we thought okay and
then they kill each other
[Laughter]
implanted on a tree in the forest by a
weird dreadlocked alien monster so and
that's their green book
[Laughter]
this different the stupidity of again
the movie we just pitch of just alien
hunts bus full of soldiers solves a
problem that this movie had which is the
soldiers are constantly having to like
ramp themselves up in order to even stay
in the movie and like constantly be
guilt trip to keep going because the
whole movie is about the predator
hunting Charlie Hunnam lights kid yes
it's all about them like going after him
and he's like come on you guys like help
me out help me hunt this thing down and
no reason to do that that's no son I
just met the guy the easy fix to me is
your whole code I don't even think you
do the cold-open that the movie did you
just start with therapy group in their
military Supermax or whatever and
everybody's riding this guy because he
says he's only in here because he saw an
alien once and the government wants to
keep it up but you established that
they've been in here for a couple years
so there is maybe that bond I did like
the cult the coop is one of the few
things I liked about this movie cuz I
was like this is going to be absolutely
insane and maybe this is entertainment
because it opens up with a spaceship
dogfight who then tears a hole in the
fabric of space and teleports to above
earth yeah and then it cuts to like
snipers orchestrating like like with
their sights trained on a like Colombian
drug deal hostage exchange I'm like okay
this guy yeah and then an alien ship
crash lands during the drug deal this is
bananas okay and then it cuts to school
for special needs children least related
movies of all time how will they ever
come together they don't they just throw
more movies at submission my issue with
the crazy space dogfighting is that they
doubled down on the problem from the
first movie where it's like again the
spaceship we know what it is like
obviously we know that there's a
predator by now in the predator movie
but the reveal of the predator in the
first minute of the movie is takes all
the mystique and danger and interest
away because it's just the first shot of
your monster alien is him just like Oh
crashing yeah they make him look like a
little punk he crashes he gets shot down
crashes and then like he does get let's
go say beat off the main character why
not he - at this point anything but this
move he's effectively fought to a
standstill by the main character in the
first scene when he doesn't even know
who the predator is know what's
happening we also get some additions to
the lore which we'll get to also yes the
Predators don't really have to aim or
work their own equipment it just kind of
acting of its own yesen it really does
because I think we make the joke in the
honest trailer for the first movie where
it's like you're a douchey big-game
hunter and like yeah that really does
and that we're sort of poking and trying
to maybe stretch a little bit because
it's a great movie but this actually
makes that true where it's like yeah
they just put the thing on and it
automatically tracks its target and -
like they don't do they're not hunters
they're just rich kids they're standing
still with their fancy toy your dad owns
the mountain yeah Owens this mountain
our after credits was right
oh yeah the Prater - yeah did that end
of a match no I don't think as keep
watching Keegan
stop doing your momma jokes how do you
circumcise a homeless man kick your mom
in the chin if your mom's vagina were a
videogame it'd be rated E for Everyone
cigarette he was good-natured and every
search of a reason to be in the movie I
forgot it was in a tapas
when does he not be in the movie I
remember this and I don't remember him
do and then he just explodes and this is
to most of them yeah strangely I also
went on this rant of the black hat
cowboy in in Halloween yeah you put a
guy you know a giant dude in a big black
cowboy hat never acknowledged it never
comes back into play later like be
wondering when what happened there
Theon Greyjoy clearly introduced to be a
master of close close-up magic and
sleight of hand
you can't give a character trait like I
do
what's up like sneaky pocketing magic
skills and never gonna have it never
never be addressed again it's just the
thing he does when he meets you it's
like well yeah count has disappeared
this that had to have been in a draft of
the script where like he has to pocket
so I'm sure he has to hide something in
front of the predator or the collating
is under a cup yeah are you sure you
lost the cloaking ball or is it behind
your ear had to have happened and get
gotten cut because otherwise why would
they introduce him everyone gets a thing
I'm saved threads I say the jokes I've
smoked the cigs and I do magic I do
magic it's filler filler it's something
to do anyways Oh business although
predator at the Magic Castle I'd watch
and the bad guy from Logan in a star
turn as a generic soldier with a very
elastic butthole and esophagus combat
training comes out of nowhere because
apparently her intro scene had a real
predator in it and they'll all bust them
Eden Starling Kate Brown who's here to
kick ass and chew bubblegum and he's all
out of he's all out he's up next okay I
guess he's just here to chew gum and I
thought that for me watching the movie
was when we were in the third act and I
pretty much suspected that we were on a
runaway train but it was at that point
but it was at that point when sterling K
Brown who to that point had was the
unquestioned antagonist of the film yes
unquestionably the antagonist of the
film literally had his head blown off
unceremonious i'm ceremoniously it was
never referenced again in the dark on
accident never referenced again that's
not I was like oh nobody knows what's
happening okay yeah okay that's that's
when I realized that we were
there was no one at the wheel someone
realized we can't have him alive at the
end yeah what would we do with him what
would we do so they just like kill him
okay great how well we established that
the printers equipment works on its own
and he turns his head shot all right
Gould Gary even the cigarette guy is the
one who I think sees it and even his
reaction is like our reaction it just
kind of looks over it's like and I guess
that that that actually tracks for me
because these guys barely know the main
antagonist of the film they haven't
really crossed paths for them a bunch
but they don't really know this just
kind of showed up I guess it makes sense
that context for that guy yeah but
that's your problem if your main
characters in your main villain unless
you're the fifth element never cross
paths yeah that was the bet yeah it's
like an anti movie um let's just keep
watching this one yeah we're like 30
seconds into the trailer I know right
the predator is back to save us all so
this is his gift to humankind or not
it's unclear like he's freaking out and
trying to escape from a prison the first
thing he does when he lands is just like
strip all the flesh off of guy from
Logan's friends in the streets the first
thing he does he makes no effort if he
is really the rogue good predator got a
way to help borne earth yeah he's not
like I'm here to talk to you about
climate change you're at the danger
yeah you know that's his love language
[Laughter]
yeah and also like the whole thing
they've clearly come across predators
before they know who they are what
they're made of like down to the genetic
level and they're just like again every
movie does this but it's like we'll just
lightly tranquilize them very quick and
just leave them up in just four hours
yeah surely this won't wear off only
slightly better than independence days
I'm gonna punch the exo-armor once in
the face and that we're not this alien
out worth 12 hours worse in this movie
is that everything goes wrong because
they do that they likely lightly
tranquilize a thing and then just
surround it by scientists you know how I
know it slightly Trek lies because
Olivia Munn shoots herself in the foot
with the same rank and is limping 11
foot tall alien but here's the thing
that's like only it's not your inciting
incident but like that's when everything
goes wrong is the moment it wakes up cut
to end of movie even less security until
they finally just walk in and point guns
at it but like no one should even be in
the room with that weird predator box at
the end but no one should be in there
you don't know what's in there it's
smaller shrink-wrapped predators like
soldiers go in after everything goes
wrong but like as they're opening it
like jacob tremble is just up on a
balcony well that's a whole other
ethical dilemma hiring miss child yeah
keep going well we'll never finish this
race
and this time the galaxy's greatest
hunter must face its most dangerous
opponent since dodge expansion spines
right I think they're attempting
hybridization yeah thanks for explaining
guys for alien hunts bad asses is all we
need three word pitch done so if you
wanna desperate battles genuinely
shocking carnage and immortal one-liners
rewatch the original yeah stick around
because the only thing here being
stalked killed and kept as a trophy is
your time you are one ugly [ __ ]
starring gie small chewy young sheldon
x-wing at Aloysius Ness Missouri Western
State University in sans dr. Tom a PhD
you versus the predator she told you not
to worry about we didn't talk about the
new the friend that is it the chiller
Prater
the other predator the first one was
predator that one is Vella predator the
whole his yeah what's his what's his
thing you know he's he's tall like they
had this chance to create a new predator
the evenin world like his the predator
counsel the predicate well they have it
they had established in predators if
this is to be considered canon that
there are two is two species of
predators hmm the ones we know yeah and
those ish kind of the big ones the
bigger ones and that the little ones are
like the little Venom's and they're all
the losers of but even still none of
that is really referenced in this film
okay again it's it's it's it's 14 layers
of complication on to something that
really should not have been complicated
yeah yeah I just was disappointed in
like his thing is that he's the predator
but bigger
yeah just like and also kind of like
slower he just kind of like dumber and
dumber he just kind of stalks you
I'm trying to think of a movie where
what if we just make the thing bigger
was like good yeah and but they keep
doing it because like the predator it
has all these cool things he can do you
know he's got the glaive he can turn
invisible he's got heat vision and a
little triple dot thing the big one
doesn't have anything cooler to do than
just be taller that's all he's got it's
like if Creed three was gonna be about
Creed fighting eight guys with guns like
that's not it's different like this
let'em thoughts he just has to box a guy
who's better boxing them him and come
out on top just like you didn't know
these push-ups that Apollo Creed it's
just the most badass guy on our planet
toe-to-toe with a thing that is a little
more badass than him can he survive like
that's it I don't need to know why it's
more badass I don't need it to be even
more batty a seer yeah like no one was
asking why does he have dreadlocks let's
go it looks cool because it's better
than the Red Lobster costume that
jean-claude Van Damme was dancing around
in and then even the things that we had
answers to with like why is he tearing
out spines to keep his trophies like
because that's something a hunter would
yeah I didn't require explanation on
that oh that they were gonna get the DNA
of another species two hybrid them it
takes all the badassness out of just
like like that's objectively like that
was mortal combat before mortal kombat
was just like why is the predator a
badass because he rips your spine out in
one piece yeah so much less badass when
it's like well who's actually doing that
to conduct some scientific research in
order to perfect know let's take them
let's take them at their word in the
world if they're taking human DNA
hybridized what does the predator
species have to gain from us are they
gonna be smaller and Pinker Jacob
Tremblay is brilliant or yeah or if
they're gonna get like the mental
aspects of human DNA they're gonna get
people on the spectrum to hybridize with
some really what wasn't it something
about colonization or no no
what the bat the big ones wanted us to
die because it would make us into a nice
little predator world for them right
well it'd be the perfect house to be our
pod house hunting environment yes also
the their depiction of people on the
spectrum is a little again like the
movie version where it's like oh yeah he
has a photographic memory which is wrong
and also he had a very runny nose I
don't think that's a thing also freeze
always like freaks out because there's a
fire alarm which is which is a thing
like but jeopardy everyone's chasing him
gunfire all over the place he's good
never comes back in the pit never comes
back if I'm an executive and I hire a
writer to come in and pitch on anything
and they're like and one of their big
ideas is hey what if autism is a
superpower like I probably don't hire
that guy because it's some weird like
it's not you can make an autistic kid a
hero in the story but they're literally
making it but like yeah making autism
like this one more step and then your
telekinetic like it's it's not it's not
don't get the point first I can't say
it's a bad now I can't say it's really
good neither was like they went normal
people what do you want me to do yeah I
wrote Monster Squad yeah I wrote monster
school man's got nods you don't remember
that it's the culture here I don't know
I don't know what you people want to
advance the comfort Reder Durotan way to
business dumb man that thing where dogs
look like their owner
it's got dogs and vs. predator the
continuation of Austrian vs. predator
for the first one they were all alien
the thing I am Legend the fly
ghostbusters this movie why does every
single nerd franchise have evil dogs in
it kena monster get an evil turtle or
something we have another tag that I
liked more until they added Mass that's
with the turtle thing that pushed it
over there and that's what made it where
the predator had Dana Carvey turtle man
as a sidekick because the first thing
was just like a the baby ninjatroll
going yeah that's what made it
delete scenes stories general army guy
blowing is half the battle
a Dutch baby half a Dutch Dutch boy
chewing scenery tiny stork
olivia nukem gone monster the monster
the only cast member that actually took
out a predator I hate mondays bread fit
should have been touched and key and
peeled dead bread redemption another
dead franchise quick whip bomb bomb just
gets to catch and then immediately
release a predator did you see that I
mean he grew an exoskeleton under his so
like a skeleton right next to skeleton
but under your skin yeah EXO means an
outside Skelton oh so now we're just
gonna fact-check every bit of science
you just throw terminology mr. smarty
pants sorry I didn't form a hypothesis
then you can put duct an experiment then
respond my conclusion to be you
snowflakes I'm gonna put dial up mr. mr.
fancy Internet with you WebMD what do
you know why your medical stuff I'm on
dial-up I don't know this we need a
trifold white poster board with some
facts written on it the science fair
alright look it's too bad cuz
there's so many good predator movies one
could have made and this was five zero
four five yeah no it didn't succeed it
and honestly most of the ones they put
in this I think also just would have
been bad on their own but the only one I
like is the is the soldiers on the bus
no yeah hunt it down and crazy war
criminals getting hunted down on the bus
I'm down with yeah and that's all it
needed to be I'm just it's raising more
and more questions for one Weiss Alfie
Allen is like British what is he doing
in the Americas army soldier program bus
and then Thomas Jane like not Thomas
Jane the the main character like
everyone else is a criminal everyone
else like did something bad yeah he just
said he saw an alien he like just means
a lot I mean therapy he that no I mean
they're trying to just like get rid of
him because he saw an alien but if
that's the case why isn't he just dead
because the moment anyone else he's the
alien and then they considered them to
go slightly rogue they're just like
killer kill him kill him so was like
kill him
yeah yeah he's like a special missions
guy it's not like listen you don't you
don't kill off a man with a butthole
that flexible army strong testicle
system is the next step clicking device
didn't even work just a test to see like
this movie another thing that annoyed me
about this film that we didn't make it
into is how they just spawn vehicles
when they need them like like cheat
codes in Grand Theft Auto yeah like get
to the choppers cute but there are
seriously just eight my chopper bikes
with their keys still outside the
military base yeah and then when they
need to get somewhere it's
that he just shows up with cop cars like
probably killed a couple cops together
yeah and then just shows up at the news
chopper like what are they what's going
on here what's going on is this movie
dirty brain off me yeah but I couldn't
make this move because we had to watch
it yet it's pretty bad and you know I I
also will forgive it if the action
itself was incredible but breach Derek
didn't through the through the jungle
stuff I really didn't like the scene
with the dogs where the dogs are just
standing still there just unloading
round after round into them they're just
standing there why why so what the dog
did the dog never paid off right like
not really gonna do like a last-minute
save at the end or something or
sacrifice itself disable the beam I kept
waiting for I kept waiting for it to
really angers dog yeah you introduced a
kindly predator dog and then just kept
showing us the kindly predator I never
paid off no no and how about that finale
where it's like you have been proven
worthy I will give you seven minutes and
then they're all like scatter into the
dark jungle like that's quick quick
everybody split up no coordination run
into the jungle we also know where the
predator is let's not just like sit here
and aim all of our guns like no let's
all skedaddle into the deep woods where
the predator surely can't hunt us one by
one
surely that's not the thing the predator
does we goodbye yeah we'll see you next
week for viral a viral sensation yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I hope you enjoyed
this
it'll be continuing off camera but sorry
yeah we're just gonna keep going is the
angry now ah there's been another
episode of honest trailer commentaries
with me
you
[Music]